hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to talk about
culture and language learning again if
you enjoy these um
discussions videos please subscribe to
my channel
the
subject oh and before i get started let
me say that today i've gone six weeks on
ukrainian and today i'm switching to
polish and you know what
the task that i put in front of me is to
work on four slavic languages
for the first four or five months of the
year to see uh to what extent it helps
me or it creates interference and stuff
like that and certainly going from
ukrainian to polish there's a lot of
similar vocabulary but so that's just to
update you now culture
and language learning
uh it's a subject that comes up all the
time
obviously when we
to effectively learn another language we
have to imitate
some aspects
of the cultural behavior
the behavior patterns of another culture
so
and i've always said that if we want to
speak
french well or chinese well or whatever
other language
we have to start thinking that we are
them and we have to
want to be part of them we want to
penetrate that world so inevitably we
want to
to some extent identify with that
culture
uh and you know even when i was learning
chinese
i think the counterpart of that is that
so much of what we find in another
culture in fact is universal so
therefore it's it's readily accessible
to us um you know
in the book that i wrote i don't have a
copy here about language learning uh on
the cover of the book i had this tree
which represented juan's tree the
parable of the crooked tree
drungzo
chinese
taoist taoist
philosopher
also has a very famous parable
where he says that he dreamt
and he dreamt that he was a butterfly
and when he woke up he didn't know if it
was a if it now he was a butterfly
dreaming that he was drunza or if that
was drunk's dreaming that he was a
butterfly and that's the kind of
call it cultural weightlessness
uh that we have to achieve in learning
another language so it's not just a
matter of being interested in the
culture
of the language we're learning we also
have to suppress
the interference from our own culture
uh you know i remember when i started
learning chinese for example i had
another canadian a diplomat studying
with me and when he found out that in
chinese to say you know are you going
to
that the chinese actually say you go not
go
it's not tremendously cultural but
that's how the language is structured
and his immediate reaction to that was
is that ever stupid
in other words he brought that back to
his own language his own culture so
that's different from my language
different from my culture therefore it's
stupid in fact you have to just allow
yourself to flow into that culture
now on the issue of culture
you know i think a lot of things in
these other cultures are
universal in their appeal otherwise we
wouldn't be interested in korean drama
russian novels um
you know french poetry whatever it might
be
and and all the great works of
literature wouldn't be translated into
50 languages these things all have
universal appeal we're all humans
uh they're all aspects that call it sort
of
human
creativity so they are tremendously
accessible but there are certain
specific call them idiosyncrasies of
certain
uh
languages cultures groups
and and not all of these are going to
appeal to us
and i sometimes think people who write
um textbooks spend too much time on
certain national festivals and uh very
sort of cultural idiosyncrasies that
that they're very proud of but may not
be of great interest to the learner uh i
find that i'm usually much more
interested in
how people interact around the dinner
table in the family at their place of
work in other words the living culture
of those people not
you know the harvest festival in korea
for example or flying carps in japan or
whatever it might be that that these
writers of textbooks always want to
present to us
so
i think culture we have to pick those
things that we like that we find
interesting
maybe there should be more freedom for
people to choose those aspects of the
culture if you're reading a history book
if you're reading a novel if you're
following korean drama you're
interacting with the culture and it
should be more up to the student to seek
out those things
that are interesting and for that matter
the same with people i often get the
comment well i was in paris and the
french were so silly and impolite and
stuff they're not all serially and
impolite but you don't have to like them
all you just have to like some you have
to find some friends so that you can
imagine yourself one of them
want to be one of them integrate into
their sphere even if it's only like a
droneza imagining himself a butterfly so
i think this issue of culture in
language learning it kind of goes both
ways
we
we need to
want to project ourselves into that
culture but we also need to have this
sense of
cultural weightlessness we need to leave
our culture you know aside take off that
coat
and try and put on this other coat so
there you have it there's a little
discussion uh on the issue of culture
and language learning and i look forward
to hearing your comments bye for now
[Music]
you